[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well there's a basic moral principle
that was for a long time conventional
wisdom in this country you probably grew
up with it it was this people deserve to
be treated as individuals judged by
their own efforts and their abilities on
the things they can control attacking
people on the basis of their race is
wrong that was the standard and for a
long time almost everybody in America
believed it our claim to believe it not
anymore
on the left is now acceptable even
encouraged to attack and discriminate
against people solely on the basis of
their skin color you're not supposed to
say anything about it but suddenly it's
everywhere considered the route for
example it's an online magazine owned by
the media company Univision it's not
some obscure hate site lurking in the
dark corners of the internet it's
considered a mainstream destination it's
got 8 million visitors a month it's
supported by huge advertisers like
Toyota here are some recent stories the
route has published quote white people
need to be better people five life hacks
or black people who want to leverage
white guilt to make white people
uncomfortable at work we need a reset
button or something for white people the
most useless types of white people
ranked there are plenty more just like
that you can google it if you want the
articles have a pretty clear intent to
attack and ridicule an entire race for
the crime of being born with certain
genes now imagine a news website that
tried to rank the most useless types of
fill-in-the-blank people would you be
embarrassed to read something like that
we hope you would be would Toyota
advertise on a site that ran a piece
like that come on of course not but it
advertises on the route and the route is
not alone not even close - alone take a
look at BuzzFeed it's one of the most
popular websites in America in 2016 that
company was valued at 1.5 billion that's
six times which Jeff Bezos paid for The
Washington Post
a couple of years ago just last week
just last week BuzzFeed published a
piece entitled 37 things white people
need to stop ruining in 2018 one of the
items on the list America now such as
wrong it's nuts it's actually suicidal
as liberals are always correctly
reminding us America is a multiracial
Society which is great and racial
societies are great multiracial ones but
they're fragile always and they only
survive when people of different races
decide
treat each other as human beings with
equal dignity when they square off into
warring tribes it's over now liberals
say they have horror white nationalism
and they should but at the same time
they're promoting it with crap like this
when rich people liberals pull up
BuzzFeed if the latest listicle on why
white people are wrecking America or
whatever they're happy to laugh along
because they're safe and the knowledge
it doesn't actually threaten them but
the joke looks a lot different when
you're not rich imagine you're a
machinist on disability in Akron you've
lost family and friends to heroin you
haven't painted your house in 20 years
everybody you know is being crushed by
the rising cost of education in health
care you're fairly certain your kids are
gonna make even less than you do
assuming jobs will even exist when the
robots get here you're worried and you
should be and now some smug private
school kid from Brooklyn is lecturing
you about how you are the problem
because the color of your skin and the
privilege it conveys how much of that
you're gonna take before you explode at
the unfairness of it all and at that
point why wouldn't you embrace a racial
identity everybody else seems to be
doing it
that's a disaster and it's not
theoretical by the way that's what's
gonna happen in this country unless
people start deciding they're gonna
treat one another as individuals rather
than as members of groups